this week we've got lost arm yogurt
drink and misleading goop I almost
thought you said misleading [ __ ] the
yogurt drink from the nut Yakult
yeah we'll get that for the sec are we
talked about putting cultures in the
[ __ ] again
no or not I put that all over my [ __ ]
orifices for our first story the South
Korean 71 year old man he was
Stephanie's dad yes milk is hot about do
it how gg he was eating this sushi and
he somehow got this flesh-eating
bacteria and he had to have his forearm
remove his forearm then he had a cut in
his hand or some what they didn't
mention a cut they were just saying that
he's already like he already doesn't
have a healthy immune system cuz he does
like dialysis and yeah he's you know
he's old 7 he's not that oh yeah anyone
yeah IV ass dialysis
his kidneys are [ __ ] yes yes type 2
diabetes and he also has hypertension
did the Desmond do enough where was this
so in South Korea and now he has
flesh-eating bacteria in his forum no no
he has no forearm I'm gonna show you
some really gross photos yeah okay I
can't like it so it's his head before it
spreads oh my god you want to smell the
death bass go wrong I can do blood it's
just cut you're the kind of person that
[ __ ] does war traveling and you go
and you go look at that body
you ready you know yeah that's Jeana
just poking at it oh my god that she
looks
[Music]
well if it's you don't wanna high-five
your face I want to I want to hook with
a needle so bad stop it if it's
flesh-eating why is it bigger shouldn't
be eaten oh holy dying all is the
bacteria taking shits in your hand still
get it I don't know
cuz this problem started about 12 hours
after eating sushi only 12 hours holy
macaroni
and then so this flesh-eating bacteria
that they found in his hand it's found
in salt water Oh
similar bacteria causes the causes
cholera but if you have a normal regular
immune system they're probably like
that's exactly what our like with the
doctor there's name cuz that gargle with
salt water that [ __ ] don't [ __ ] faze
me the ocean water dog I gotta go public
pool water to some oh yeah Loreen that
[ __ ] you're just having a fun time like
i goggled your pool water with swimmin
around getting your mouth but do you
actually like once it's in i don't
swallow it but you still like gargle
I mean I'm just like swimming when
there's swimming you have water in your
mouth you're spitting it out you're like
a cupid at a fountain like you jealous
[ __ ] all my sore throat in Hawaii I
[ __ ] gargled like everyday that [ __ ]
went away
those are like fish come in there and
[ __ ] yeah but it's salt and embankment I
don't know worse foot flakes bro
oh good freak they don't survive in a
salt in a high salt environment you know
in our minds they do did your mom ever
give you the [ __ ] water full of salt
and yet The Gargoyle with that it's
because like bacteria cannot survive in
water with salt not [ __ ] skin flake
water yeah that's still clean no I mean
what's bad about skin flakes
it's these in your mouth it sticks to
your [ __ ] interlining
I feel like the sea is alive and I feel
like the sink water is stale it is alive
you don't want anything alive cuz you
ready have some alive [ __ ] in there and
you're trying to kill the alive [ __ ]
yeah yeah see that's just like this that
makes me so scared to go outside please
tell me it's like a budget no because
like because like the smallest things
can happen like you accidentally scrape
your like your ankle on a [ __ ] that's
why I say girl if it's your time to go
it's your time ago so don't [ __ ]
sweat the [ __ ] just [ __ ] jump off the
plane in case it sucks like just a
flesh-eating disease just for like
poking a [ __ ] like touching a
crosswalk button or something [ __ ] sucks
yeah man I just like to think that
people like this probably did something
really bad so they're just being
punished damn he got away with five
different diseases he probably beat his
kids and wife and everything right God
like [ __ ] this guy apart if I had that
disease though I would use it until they
had to chop my hand off like I would
just read no I would keep keep my hand
in the fleece sweater and just keep it
covered and the one I'm at the
supermarket oh boy that's $20 then I'll
slide it out of people probably been
French ended because it was 25 days
after yeah when they have to amputate it
it was spreading yeah what maximize the
[ __ ] out of it with bunnies my first
thought is to scare kids cuz I'll hide
it and then I'll be like this is what
happens when you do drugs and then just
scare the [ __ ] out of them you bad ass
I'm just focused on like losing a lemon
you guys say like how am I gonna [ __ ]
with people before I officially who's it
gonna love it that's the only way right
all I was thinking about is if I can
high-five somebody and that blood just
burst
yes I wouldn't want them to like give me
my arm after they chop it off so I can
preserve it and put in my room but
that's ugly you don't like ugly things
don't lie to yourself no but I mean
don't don't imagine is like in beasts
he's my head yeah how many people can
say this is my hand in a jar how many of
your teeth do you have I used to keep
them and then you [ __ ] weirdo
we have teeth too yeah when I was a
kidding you keepin cuz I give it to you
in those cute little like tooth shaped
plastic box and I have a bunch of boy
will you shave bucks
yeah I just give me a ziploc bag oh you
guys need to ever recreate me I have my
wisdom teeth save okay noted if I if my
body's lost somewhere you know that in
my room you can find it and then you
could clone me or we can just get one of
your instruments and then just that's
true we're better off there dude leaving
a lot of DNA around yeah we got to do
you think when they use the DNA of that
time like they clone you at that age or
what if you're reborn all over again
yeah cuz that's what they did with that
land yeah they gotta grow you yeah we
got a growing around they do that they
do that with the doggies you know that
like you can get your doggy cloned now
yeah well she just said like the lamina
oh yeah I think they do it in South
Korea actually like being you but it's
like 50,000 dollars or so as well yo
your people are killing it man you
should be proud of you crazy I mean but
y'all killin it but it's you know you
know what I would do if I was a kid and
I found out like some kid was born like
being a clone in laboratory I would make
fun of them you [ __ ] chemical baby
yeah they're just the copy your
artificial and they can even make you
look better you know they're gonna get
you real fast though you'll be like but
your old Emily if I was a kid like oh
you're me you lab-grown [ __ ] my lab
grown I bullied a lot of kids growing up
and I was bullied a lot
wait this girl you still like sit behind
me like pull on my hair was funny
she's fat now I used to be called
pancake why go and fly over you that's a
cute name though pumpkin because like
all my friends they were skinny so they
were like the Cinderella's and I was
like the transportation actually really
really skinny or something I don't know
this hat your arms like this if you
liked you grow in my eye
it was mainly I got mainly bullied for
my big eyes and for being skinny so that
was like the main thing like they would
always be okay for your beautiful
features it was made fun of me because
of my ABS no they were mean like [ __ ]
praying mantis yeah alien no they might
just like you so I don't know if this is
a guy thing or a girl thing or whatever
but have you ever looked at someone and
they look so funny to you that you can't
stop making fun of them specifically it
was so funny when girls had a mustache
then we I would make up names like hairy
sue or like hairy scary to their place
ya wanna kill
it's cuz like I couldn't control myself
I didn't know I don't know I just
thought it was funny
Biden elbows heard their feelings but I
just couldn't stop all you in be on a
show and then they're gonna be like on
the Maury show yes this guy used to pick
on me now look at me now yeah like well
like if they had like a like a huge
forehead and in like a small like if
their face look like myself okay so it's
[Applause]
probably all the features weren't
dispersed evenly it looked like a mean
like the [ __ ] face filter mean right
yeah no face Will Smith me when they
[ __ ] smelled his face in the middle
they should say well that's how bullying
starts right like or or well I dunno the
mean kind of bullying where you just
want to dominate people and be [ __ ]
and [ __ ] up and like bully them and
like I don't know I just think sometimes
kids go overboard and they can't control
themselves and then something becomes
too funny and they can't stop I think
have you guys seen that Netflix movie I
know you have I totally have it so can
the movie called to all the boys I've
loved before is it that asian girl yeah
anything to do with being Asian
it's just this chick I love it that was
a really good I haven't seen I saw I saw
the trailer I was looking forward to
check it out is it good it's like a
chicken it's like the chick theme like a
teenage chick pea do I would I feel like
a 11 year old girl when I watch it yeah
hell yeah I want to feel like that yeah
yeah so because of that show you're cool
they are selling out and grocery stores
all over the place why because they were
drinking bad in there yeah there's a
seam because you Korean eyes it well in
the movie they called it's Korean yogurt
smoothie the little sister brings it to
the white guy that's driving them and
he's like oh my god I don't know check
it III don't know because there's no
that's what they call it in the movie
though a Korean yogurt there's just
companies that are like so for example
latte where I think it's picky but all
those things right yeah for the longest
time like I would fight with my career
friends and be like no that's Japanese
they're like no it's Korean it's both I
thought it was nice because don't they
make Mexican candy they make Mexicans
all day babe they're international right
it's like saying like [ __ ] Hershey
but the funny thing is it's both because
it was a Korean guy that went to Japan
in college and sold little bubble gum
and then he built the company in Japan
and then he went back to Korea yeah cool
yeah it could be one of those lotte - it
could be the same thing where it's like
uh no it was founded by a Japanese dude
in the headquarters is in Tokyo okay I
try to help okay
okay is this balota is actually a Korean
person that built the company in Japan
first and then brought it back to Korea
I didn't notice how you pronounced it
not like how do you say yeah call them
Vietnamese do you have you been drinking
a sensor kid since you're a kid yeah
Asian stuff which is so funny like I
ended up marrying a TV but yeah he would
always bite you've been conditioning
girls money no it's funny because they
never liked can you another thing he put
a spell on you and then once because one
time when I'm down he may be true their
work yeah the only Asian that you saw
was the guy that worked at Panda Express
not even against Braga doesn't Mexican
you probably would have been a [ __ ] if
you grew up in Monterey Park everybody's
fine cuz I didn't like I didn't like
Asian girls until I moved to the sgb oh
really
yeah cuz they were what happened to my
cousin my cousin had a whole bunch of
Asian girl girlfriends once you moved to
I think you went because there weren't
pretty Asian girls where I grew grew up
at and they're like their mom still
dress them in [ __ ] and then when I came
here I was like mmm
baby you looking like an import model
have you guys heard of goop yeah would
you use cope with it huh that's right
the really loud it is it a snap
no this company its Gwyneth Paltrow's
company where it's like a website and
[ __ ] and then they have is that we're
putting a glitter bagina yeah yeah
that's it like the vajazzle stuff yeah
all this weird [ __ ] and so now they have
agreed to pay one hundred and forty five
thousand dollars for misleading
customers about this Jade egg that they
were telling their customers to put
upside like up inside their vagina Wow
why there's somebody who's do put your
[ __ ] shin a bagina thing is that the
same things that like the key ball
exercise well they're saying it's for
that and they're also saying to increase
sexual energy oh my god look if you fell
for this you [ __ ] deserve it really
dumbass it's like this you know like
you're on the river mountainside that
like [ __ ] leaves and gems and like
spiritual healing and like crystals and
crystals and [ __ ] like I put crystals up
my vagina so I can [ __ ] sing so I put
[ __ ] stones in the soil and now she's
back no I think it's find out a hobby
but when you spend all your money on
though I'm like [ __ ] that cannot save
you from being broke right crystal
energized water yeah don't [ __ ] it the
rough in your water
oh it's cuz they don't operate on logic
you know it's just insanity I think
people that are like not balanced like
if you're too logical you're too [ __ ]
crazy
and if you're also too emotional you're
[ __ ] dumb as balls hmm mm-hmm you got
to be right in the middle I don't think
they're that crazy I mean they're
probably is like a little bit of truth
to it but to the extent right how many
stones you own girl right now but I'm
just saying like yeah I do believe in
like there's energy and [ __ ] and in
certain things and then yeah but you got
your priorities together that they don't
realize it's escapism yeah you don't
realize like I'm gonna go by myself cuz
life is just not working right now my
[ __ ] chakras are not lined up it's
like [ __ ] cuz you're not paying the
damn bills and you're [ __ ] burning
bridges with people and all kinds of
[ __ ] is happening but you can't see it
it's because you're still enjoy a wine
then they get fired but they're like I
need to go to India to find myself to
get a new job yeah it's like what it's
my [ __ ] heart
yeah if the purpose is to [ __ ] be
responsible but they're like no I got it
I gotta go find myself right yeah so now
goop has agreed to settle with
California prosecutors there's that's so
funny because in Modern Family there's
this one actress chick bag started a
company called NERP and she makes dumb
[ __ ] - like oh is it making fun of her
yeah pretty much yeah it's just stickers
that like bounce you out or [ __ ] like
that did anyone get hurt or it's just
like people are like ice
money no it's uh I got your [ __ ] not no
there's no there's a string I hope so oh
but how did they prove that didn't work
either so they're saying that they all
of this thought although their claims
it's not scientifically backed by
anything so then that's why they're
agreeing to pay because they're like
alright well we made all these claims
that aren't back yet oh that's hilarious
what about like all the other crystal
shops you know the healing crystal shops
shouldn't they technically get seed to
you because I'm [ __ ] rubbed and
[ __ ] rock on my knee the other day my
bruising go away so what the [ __ ] big or
famous there's not not that big of a
magnifying glass on them
[Music]